Richard Dolan is one of the world's most  lauded UFO researchers and historians  firstly you said around 1962 there was  an explosion of nuclear bombs off the  coast of Hawaii  and I think it was 36 nuclear bombs and  there was a UFO there that got shot down  if I heard correctly  can you explain what happened  yeah that was part of something known as  operation Dominic from I think 1945 till  the  1998 end of the 20th century uh the  world experienced I think 2050 nuclear  detonations second to last Dominic uh  detonation and this man saw and  the UFO like Zoom by and presumably he  thought it was it went into the ocean  he learned later he's doing cross-train  with radar operators later that day and  he  in the scuttlebutt learned that they  were tracking  UFO they track UFOs he said all the time  during detonation